[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a signé de partout quoi c'est
lui-même des yeux du nez des oreilles
c'était horrible
il avait à plusieurs reprises menacées
soit de la tuer soit de se tuer si elle
le quittait
pour moi c'était logique que c'était lui
ça pouvait être personne d'autre il dit
je suis parti la DT ton corps en vie il
est venu de suite me voir pour m'aider à
Bernard j'ai jamais tué ma femme c'est
pas moi c'est pas possible
[Musique]
Yvelines n'avait pas seulement une
relation intime avec Robert mais
également avec François Evelyne aurait
pu révéler au grand jour l'existence de
leur relation pourquoi veut-il la cacher
est-ce que ça en fait pas un suspect
formidable
1er octobre 2007 à Castelsarrasin dans
le Tarn-et-Garonne
il est 17h45
[Musique]
après une journée passée en cours Julie
une collégienne de 14 ans rentre chez
elle
ses parents sont divorcés et depuis 6
mois elle vit seule dans cet appartement
avec sa mère
Evelyne Furon 52 ans
et ce soir là en arrivant chez elle
Julie réalise que quelque chose ne va
pas
je regarde un peu partout je l'appelle
personne me répond et quand j'avance au
niveau du couloir en fait je tourne ma
tête au niveau de la chambre et là je
vais avoir en fait elle était sur le lit
mais je la vois pas
elle était recouverte en fait d'un grand
et elle est pas encore en chemise de
nuit
[Musique]
et donc je lui parle elle me répond pas
elle avait un peu elle avait son bras
qui est tombé un peu du lit et
c'est un peu bleu violet et donc moi sur
le coup je croyais qu'elle était malade
que fallait que je l'aide donc je me
rapproche d'elle et
en fait je lève le drap et
[Musique]
et là j'ai vu que
elle était décédée
malgré le choc Julie réalise que le
meurtrier est peut-être encore dans
l'appartement elle doit fuir au plus
vite
je me suis retrouvé en fait et je
pensais qu'il était là et que j'allais
passer je pensais que j'allais passer
et je suis parti pour demander de l'aide
pour qu'on puisse m'aider l'adolescent
de s'échappe dans la rue
et rencontre un voisin
je t'en prie vite à deux mois appelle
maman elle est décédée
elle me toit explique-moi calmement moi
je dis non non tu appelles donc il a
appelé la police est venue aussitôt
le commissariat de Castelsarrasin est à
moins de 800 m les policiers arrivent en
quelques minutes à peine
et une fois sur place ils ne peuvent que
constater l'évidence
[Musique]
dans la chambre d'Evelyne furlon ils
sont confrontés à une scène horrible le
visage de la victime est méconnaissable
la quinquagénaire a été étranglée et il
ne faut pas chercher trop loin l'arme du
crime
elle est toujours là près du corps
l'arme du crime c'est un cordon
électrique qui est le câble
d'alimentation de la radio la coloration
de la peau était extrêmement rosé
violette ce qui témoignait d'une d'une
importante force lors de la
strangulation au lien le tueur a fait un
double tour avec le câble électrique
pour être anglais très violemment
Évelyne furlant une strangulation si
importante qu'elle a occasionné des
dégâts ignobles
impossible pour Julie d'oublier cette
vision macabre
c'était vraiment bien ouvert et il a
essayé de partout quoi c'est lui même
des yeux du nez des oreilles de la
bouche
du coup nous partons de partout ça va
être toute la tête en quoi
c'était horrible
le SRPJ de Toulouse est saisi de
l'affaire et comme toujours les
investigations débutent avec les experts
scientifiques
les techniciens en identification
criminelle de la police judiciaire ont
passé un temps fou dans cet appartement
pour essayer de trouver tout indice
pouvant aider l'enquête comme on dit
c'est à dire la salive d'éventuelles
tâches de sperme de sang
de cheveux
d'empreinte digitales également toute la
maison est passée au peigne fin une
chose est certaine l'arme du crime n'a
pas été apportée de l'extérieur car dans
le salon les policiers retrouvent ce
poste radio auquel manque son câble
d'alimentation
enfin sans attendre les résultats de
l'autopsie les enquêteurs sont à même de
déterminer lors du crime et cela grâce à
certains détails
elle est découverte il est à peu près
18h elle est toujours en chemise de nuit
les tasses de café du petit déjeuner
sont encore là de toute évidence la vie
s'est arrêtée le matin même en fait
le médecin qui constate le décès
confirme l'hypothèse grâce au relevé de
température sur le cadavre il data
proximativement la mort au matin même un
peu avant 8h30
en attendant les résultats des analyses
des différents prélèvements les
policiers remarquent une chose étonnante
la porte n'a pas été fracturée ce qui ne
laisse que trois hypothèses possibles
ça veut dire que soit madame furlant a
ouvert à la personne qui qui l'a
étranglée soit cette personne avait la
clé soit cette personne était déjà dans
les lieux
Évelyne furent connait ses tel son
meurtrier un autre indice semble
conforter cette hypothèse
sur le canapé dans le séjour se trouve
deux oreillers et une couverture
laissant penser que quelqu'un a dormi
sur ce canapé cette nuit là
alors qui a dormi chez Evelyne cette
nuit-là pourrait-il s'agir du meurtrier
Julie la fille de la victime doit être
entendue au plus vite
[Musique]
la jeune femme révèle alors aux
policiers l'identité de la personne qui
a passé la nuit chez eux la veille
il s'agit d'un homme en l'occurrence il
s'agit de l'ex petit ami de sa mère
Robert Koutama un antillais de 55 ans et
voici ce que Julie raconte à la police
à enlever sa veste pour se mettre à
l'aise sur le canapé et
moi bon je l'appréciais pas vraiment
donc je lui ai lancé un petit peu
technique et je lui ai dit mais
qu'est-ce que tu fais
il me dit non mais rien j'aimerais
discuter un peu avec ta mère il y a pas
eu de il y a pas eu de cris il y a pas
eu de dispute violente mais enfin il y a
eu une manifestement une explication
entre deux et Robert Koutama d'après
Julie Marie lui aurait dit tu peux pas
faire ça tu peux pas me quitter comme ça
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
donc je suis parti dans la chambre après
je sais pas ce que je disais au policier
je sais pas vraiment qu'est-ce qui s'est
dit
retirer dans sa chambre Julie n'a rien
entendu de plus
ensuite la jeune fille raconte qu'au
cours de la soirée sa mère est passée la
voir pour la rassurer
il va s'en aller il y a pas de problème
encore
à peu près c'est comme ça
Julie se couche et le lendemain matin à
son réveil elle découvre que Robert
Koutama est toujours là et quelque chose
intrigue la jeune fille
il y avait Robert il y avait Robert qui
était là dans la cuisine et je me sens
Figueras il nous regardait ma mère elle
se préparait parce qu'elle avait
rendez-vous pour du travail donc très
contente c'est préparer spawner faisait
le retour entre salle à manger
chambre et salle de bain et il arrêtait
pas de la regarder il a fixé il a fixé
je trouvais ça bizarre enfin inhabituel
du moins venant de lui parce que
pourquoi la fixer autant je sais pas
vers 7h20 l'adolescente se prépare à
quitter l'appartement et dit au revoir à
sa mère qu'elle laisse seule avec Robert
Koutama
à partir de la Julie n'aura plus aucune
nouvelle de sa mère
alors Robert Koutama a-t-il quelque
chose à voir avec la mort d'Évelyne
Furlan
pour le savoir les enquêteurs décident
de partir à sa rencontre mais auparavant
ils veulent en savoir plus sur Évelyne
qui était-elle quelqu'un pouvait-il lui
en vouloir
maman de trois enfants
issu de deux unions différentes
Evelyne Furlan était divorcé depuis six
ans du père de Julie
cette femme de 52 ans était très
croyante et semblait unanimement
apprécié dans son entourage c'est ce que
nous confirme l'une de ses meilleures
amies que nous avons retrouvé mais qui a
préféré garder l'anonymat
elle a tout pour elle quoi elle allait à
l'église et c'est quelqu'un qui aurait
fait tout pour ces gosses et quelqu'un
qui était patiente qui était à l'écoute
c'est quelqu'un qui même si elle a rien
elle va faire tout pour t'aider
[Musique]
joyeuse
dès qu'elle pouvait aider à le faisait
c'est un extraordinaire vraiment
pourtant la vie ne fait pas été tendre
avec Evelyne
diabétique et souffrant de problèmes aux
reins elle est sans emploi et percevait
une pension d'invalidité
elle venait d'ailleurs de décrocher un
rendez-vous important et reprenez espoir
de retrouver un travail
[Musique]
mais derrière ce portrait sans histoire
les enquêteurs découvrent que la mère de
famille cachait un secret
et comme souvent c'est son téléphone
portable qui va se révéler bavard
les policiers découvrent un numéro de
téléphone qui est très souvent utilisé
très souvent utilisé par par Evelyne
donc ils vont faire identifier
l'utilisateur de cette ligne
téléphonique et ils vont tomber sur un
individu qui se prénomme François
les policiers ne connaissent pas ce
François jusque la personne n'avait
mentionné ce prénom
ce sont les nombreux textos échangés
entre Evelyne et cet homme qui vont
révéler la vraie nature de leur relation
là ils vont découvrir que finalement
Évelyne n'avait pas seulement une
relation intime avec Robert mais
également avec François et visiblement
c'est de là se voyait très régulièrement
très souvent et en tout cas il
communiquait beaucoup
les enquêteurs fouillent alors la vie de
l'homme en question
il habite à Castelsarrasin il est marié
il est jamais tombé dans une affaire de
de droit commun de violence ou de d'un
quelconque délit ou crime
l'enquête démontre alors que non
seulement ce quinquagénaire entretient
une relation intime avec Evelyne mais
qu'en plus elle ne date pas d'hier et
visiblement il connaît Évelyne furlant
depuis très longtemps en fait ce sont
déjà sortis ensemble quand ils étaient
jeunes
et ils se sont retrouvés par hasard et
ça a été de nouveau le même coup de cœur
au fur et à mesure des investigations
une conviction se forge doucement chez
les enquêteurs le criminel se trouve
forcément dans l'entourage de cette
femme sans histoire
il y a Robert Koutama l'expédite
mais aussi François l'amant militaire
l'un de ces deux hommes en voulait-il à
la mère de famille au point de
l'assassiner sauvagement et si oui pour
quelle raison
[Musique]
c'est Julie la fille d'Évelyne qui va
apporter une indication essentielle à
propos de Robert Koutama
Evelyne et lui se sont bel et bien
aimées pendant quatre ans mais petit à
petit des tensions sont apparues
Julie raconte et dispute dont elle a été
témoin j'avais compris dans leur dispute
ou que apparemment il avait eu trompé
plusieurs fois
il était quand même assez agressif au
moins au niveau de la voix il avait la
voix
c'est pour moi ça faisait ça faisait
bizarre parce que j'étais petite et ça
m'impressionner parce que il devait la
voix il sa criait
après une fois je sais que j'étais sur
le canapé
j'ai allongé et il y avait une dispute
avec ma mère j'ai voulu prendre la
défense de ma mère donc je lis mal parlé
et ça lui a pas pu il avait bu et
s'approchait de moi il m'a levé la main
sans me taper mais il m'a levé la main
dessus
[Musique]
Julie déteste Robert Koutama à tel point
qu'à la fin de son audition elle
n'hésite pas à dire que pour elle c'est
forcément lui qui a tué sa mère il avait
fait des menaces
je te tuerai et voilà donc pour moi ça
pouvait être que lui c'était sûr pour
moi que c'était lui parce que ce matin
là comme je suis parti à l'école il
était là donc pour moi c'était logique
le soir quand je suis rentrée à la
maison que elle était toute seule pour
moi c'était logique que c'était lui ça
pouvait être personne d'autre on a un
coupable désigné
par quelqu'un de très proche qui est une
enfant qui est une adolescente et qui
est une fois de plus témoin de rien mais
tu es moins de d'un ressenti
dès le lendemain de l'audition de Julie
au petit matin
les policiers interpellent Robert
Koutama
et ils n'y vont pas demain morte ils ne
connaissent pas la dangerosité de la
personne ils utilisent un bélier pour
défoncer la porte et il le trouve à 6h
du matin dans son séjour
ne comprend pas du tout ce qui se passe
il se laisse appréhender sans aucune
difficulté parce que c'est conforme à
son caractère
les policiers perquisitionnent le
domicile de Kutama et d'emblée
intéressant
la présence d'un jean qui est encore
mouillé et qui est en train de sécher
deux t-shirts qui semblent présenter
d'ailleurs des traces de de sang des
traces brunâtres
Robert Koutama a lavé ce linge la veille
précisément le jour de la mort d'Évelyne
[Musique]
on retrouve surtout une boîte de
pastilles de détergent donc trois trois
pastilles ont été utilisés il y a encore
leur emballage cellophane sur le la
table de la machine à laver 3 pastilles
de détergent pour une seule lessive
étrange les policiers ne sont pas au
bout de leur surprise le passage du
Bluestar dans la voiture de Robert
Koutama se révèle positif
la portière avant gauche va réagir aux
produits ce qui veut dire qu'on retrouve
des traces de sang sur la portière
conducteur c'est de dire qu'il a pu se
frotter s'il avait du sang sur son jean
en fermant la porte ou quelque chose
comme ça donc tout ça entre les
vêtements encore mouillés qui ont été
lavés la veille plus les détergents en
quantité importante
tout laisse penser quand même qu'il y a
un truc qui va pas
Robert Koutama est placé en garde à vue
au SRPJ de Toulouse il doit s'expliquer
[Musique]
dès le lendemain l'arrestation de Robert
Koutama fait la une des journaux
et lorsqu'ils apprennent la nouvelle ses
proches n'ont pas leurs yeux
c'est le cas de Xavier Sanchez un ami du
meurtrier présumé
[Musique]
la douche froide
le patron de Robert Koutama n'imagine
pas non plus que cette honnête maçon
puisse être coupable
[Musique]
c'est pas possible
tout le monde s'est posé la question
dans l'entreprise comment Robert aurait
pu faire ça c'est pas possible il a pour
nous c'était
en tombait des nuits
un homme très souriant
très jovial sociable très sympa
travailleur voilà enfin moi je l'image
de Robert c'est ça c'est ce visage avec
ce grand sourire toujours rigolé enfin
[Musique]
quelqu'un de bien quelqu'un de bien
alors que des accusations de meurtre
pèsent sur lui Robert Koutama se montre
incroyablement serein
même lorsqu'il est présenté au juge
d'instruction
puis en face d'un homme particulièrement
tranquille très calme qui paraît presque
détaché par rapport à ce qui se passe on
est quand même sur une enquête
criminelle donc il y a nécessairement
une forme de tension et lorsque je viens
lui notifier la prolongation de sa garde
à vue il ne laisse vraiment paraître
aucune émotion
et Robert Koutama répète qui n'a rien à
voir avec la mort d'Évelyne Furlan
il nie toute responsabilité dans ces
événements il dit je suis accusé du
meurtre de ma compagne je n'y suis pour
rien je suis parti elle était encore en
vie
koutamar réponse à tout même lorsque les
enquêteurs lui demandent pourquoi ses
habits sont tachés de sang
il va indiquer que il a des problèmes
d'hémorroïdes qu'il a des pertes de sang
et que ce sang c'est son sang
et puis concernant les pastilles de
détergents dont on a retrouvé les
emballages chez lui
Koutama explique les avoir utilisés pour
déboucher son lave-linge et non pour
effacer des traces de sang
[Musique]
on sait que la machine à laver le linge
était bouchée et il pensait pouvoir
utiliser ce produit Tarax pour déboucher
cette la machine à laver le lunch alors
évidemment les policiers vont abattre
leur carte maîtresse et ils vont dire
mais la fille Julie marie dit que c'est
vous monsieur elle dit que c'est vous il
en incompréhension totale il ne comprend
pas que Julie Marie le remette en cause
il ne comprend pas ses reproches parce
que selon lui tout allait bien avec elle
et tout allait bien avec Evelyne il
considère qu'ils sont toujours ensemble
que certes il y a des hauts et des bas
certes il lui peut il a pu lui arriver
d'être violent mais verbalement
Robert Koutama expliquait pas le quitter
le couple ne vivait plus ensemble c'est
vrai mais c'était un choix
c'était simplement pour qu'elle se
rapproche de sa mère qui était malade et
pas du tout pour se séparer de lui donc
il présente Evelyne Furlan comme sa
compagne actuelle
Robert Kouta malle répète Evelyne
c'était la femme de sa vie
Evelyne pour lui c'était
comme il m'a dit une fois au moment où
ils sont séparés un petit peu il me dit
je te le dis à toi ça se dit pas en trop
de chantier mais je peux te dire que
elle je l'aime voilà ce qu'il m'a dit
[Musique]
d'ailleurs une semaine avant le drame
Xavier avait croisé Robert et Evelyne
ensemble selon lui tout allait bien ils
avaient même des projets
et
elle m'a dit est-ce que Robert t'a parlé
des projets qu'on a j'ai dit vaguement
pour les fêtes de Noël ils avaient
l'intention de partir en Martinique
pour prospecter pour voir si
éventuellement il pouvait voilà à la
retraite au bout peut-être avant partir
en Martinique voilà pour être chaud
Robert Koutama Evelyne furlant
étaient-ils toujours amoureux ou au
contraire était-il en train de se
séparer provoquant la colère de Robert
sans preuve ni mobile avéré les
policiers demandent à Robert Koutama de
préciser son emploi du temps dans les
heures qui précèdent le drame
d'abord il explique qu'il est bien
arrivé chez Evelyne la veille de sa mort
ce soir là il est arrivé chez Madame
furet il leur a proposé de d'aller faire
se faire un restaurant elles n'ont pas
voulu il a dormi sur le canapé lit
il a regardé la télévision
toujours selon ses déclarations le
lendemain matin tout le monde se
réveille et se prépare à partir
Aubert Koutama indique qu'il est parti
de cet appartement un quart d'heure
après Julie pour retourner chez lui à
Toulouse il indique qu'il a préféré
partir tôt parce que ça peut paraître un
peu effectivement précipité parce que il
n'avait pas de permis de conduire à
cette époque-là et que il considérait
qu'à cette heure-là de la journée il
avait moins de chance de se faire
contrôler sur la route Robert Koutama
aurait donc quitté Evelyne à 7h45
mais au fur et à mesure que
l'interrogatoire avance il s'embrouille
sur les horaires et se montre de moins
en moins convaincant
pour les policiers ça ne peut être que
lui ils ont personne d'autre il est le
dernier à l'avoir vu vivante il a des
tâches de sang sur ses vêtements dans sa
voiture il a acheté un détergent il dit
que tout va bien dans le couple mais on
sait que c'est pas complètement vrai
donc tout ça la bille formidablement
bien
[Musique]
on sent beaucoup de versions changeantes
en fonction des arguments que les
enquêteurs peuvent lui mettre sous les
yeux on sent des explications très
variables des choses qui tiennent pas la
route la juge décide de mettre Robert
kudama en examen
mais l'homme va bientôt être au centre
d'un énorme coup de théâtre
Robert Koutama va-t-il partir en prison
tout le laisse à croire mais un élément
a priori anodin va tout changer
lors de la perquisition de l'appartement
de Robert Koutama indiqué de caisse
avait été saisi il correspond à l'achat
des pastilles de détergents
[Musique]
on retrouve un ticket de caisse
du jour de la mort des vignes Furlan
donc le 1er octobre 2007 un ticket de
caisse d'un tissu supermarché pas très
loin du domicile de monsieur poutama qui
est horodaté à 9h14
c'est certain à 9h14 Robert Koutama
était donc à Toulouse
puisqu'il faut presque 1h30 pour
parcourir le trajet de Castelsarrasin où
vit Evelyne à Toulouse cela signifie que
Robert s'il est bien le meurtrier aurait
tué Evelyne avant 7h50
[Musique]
et souvenez-vous Julie la fille
d'Evelyne a quitté l'appartement de sa
mère aux environs de 7h20 Robert Koutama
a décrit comme calme ce matin-là par
Julie ce serait donc transformé en homme
violent au point d'étrangler son
ex-compagne en moins de 30 minutes ce
n'est pas impossible mais c'est peu
crédible
je ne comprends pas comment Robert
Koutama peut en une demi-heure
dégoupillé s'énerver à l'école au point
d'aller étrangler ville furlant alors
qu'ils sont passés la nuit ensemble et
qu'il n'y a aucun élément qui permet de
déterminer qu'il y a eu ces disputes
initiales avant les faits
autre élément troublant qui va semer le
doute chez les enquêteurs le retour des
analyses des tâches de sang retrouvés
sur le jean et dans la voiture de Robert
Koutama il ne s'agit pas du tout de ce
qu'imaginer les policiers ce sens n'est
pas tout celui des vignes c'est le sien
il souffre d'hémorroïdes et ce qu'il
avait expliqué aux enquêteurs le son qui
était présent dans sa voiture le sang
qui est présent chez lui c'est son sang
et c'est démontré par le laboratoire de
police scientifique de Toulouse
non seulement cette preuve s'évanouit
mais un témoignage va bientôt aider à
disculper Robert Koutama
[Musique]
en poursuivant l'enquête les policiers
vont mettre la main sur un témoin
capital l'homme est balayeur municipal à
Castelsarrasin et c'est surtout un ami
de la famille d'Evelyne furlant il a une
révélation très étonnante à faire selon
lui le matin de la mort d'Évelyne il
l'aurait croisé en ville il a été
entendu à trois reprises à trois
reprises il a toujours certifié qu'il
était convaincu qu'il était sûr que le
matin des faits il avait rencontré
Évelyne furlant Évelyne était pomponnée
coiffée maquillée il y en avait
d'ailleurs fait la remarque elle lui
avait fait la bise et lui avait dit j'ai
un rendez-vous pour l'emploi très
important il faut que j'y aille l'homme
donne même une heure approximative aux
alentours de 9h30
et cet élément nous sentait totalement
Robert Koutama puisque Robert Koutama
est à 9h15 à Toulouse et que l'on sait
qui ne peut avoir fait le trajet en
moins d'une demi-heure entre
castelsarzan et Toulouse
si le balayeur dit vrai Evelyne était
vivante à 9h30 le crime c'est donc
forcément produit après
mais il y a quelque chose qui cloche
lorsque le corps d'Evelyne furlant est
découvert elle était habillée en chemise
de nuit
elle se serait donc déshabillée en
rentrant de son rendez-vous à Pôle
Emploi cela paraît peu probable le
témoignage du balayeur n'est finalement
pas jugé fiable le souci c'est que cette
personne va nous donner beaucoup de
versions différentes c'est quelqu'un qui
effectivement
de la vie de des personnes qui
travaillent avec lui et peut tout à fait
effectivement confondre avec un autre
jour
au final la justice va considérer qu'il
n'existe en l'état pas suffisamment de
charge à l'encontre de Robert Koutama
pour le maintenir en détention l'homme
est libéré et immédiatement il va avoir
ses amis pour les convaincre en quelque
sorte de son innocence
et là c'était dur quoi il était
étonnant
de l'été qu'ils avaient passé ensemble
et tout
tout ils comprenait pas ce qui lui
arrivait
déjà
Évelyne il me dit je l'avais plus jamais
et moi que qu'est-ce que je vais devenir
si tu as rien fait
tu vas retourner au travail mon gars il
est venu de suite me voir à l'entreprise
pour s'expliquer pour me dire Bernard
j'ai jamais tué ma femme c'est pas moi
c'est pas possible moi je suis pour rien
[Musique]
donc forcément si c'est plus des trois
verres Koutama c'est quelqu'un d'autre
et les policiers n'ont pas l'ombre d'une
piste nouvelle va falloir qu'il cherche
les enquêteurs se tournent alors
naturellement vers françois l'amant
d'Evelyne ils vont bientôt réaliser que
l'homme ne leur a pas tout dit
[Musique]
François le militaire pourrait-il être
lié à la mort d'Évelyne furlant les
policiers décident de l'interroger et
lui demandent tout d'abord de préciser
la nature de sa relation avec la
quinquagénaire et là surprise il affirme
Kevin et lui n'était pas amant il évoque
une relation de tendresse et d'amitié de
confident beaucoup plus qu'une relation
sexuelle
j'ai décidé de prendre de la distance et
de ce fait je ne couchais plus avec elle
nous ne faisions que nous appeler
[Musique]
la dernière fois que j'ai eu un rapport
intime avec elle cela remonte à mars
[Musique]
il explique qu'il est par ailleurs marié
qu'il tient à son couple et qu'il a
surtout pas envie de perdre d'annéantir
son couple donc il conteste en réalité
avoir une relation sentimentale avec
les policiers ont le sentiment que
François leur cache quelque chose
pour avoir le cœur net ils vont
effectuer un prélèvement ADN et les
résultats scientifiques vont leur
réserver une surprise
quand le retour des analyses ADN tombe
les policiers n'en reviennent pas
le sperme retrouvé par la police
scientifique sur la couette des vignes
furent
n'est autre que celui de François
[Musique]
or François lors de son audition dit
qu'il a plus de relations sexuelles avec
elle depuis très longtemps donc
évidemment c'est un flagrant délith
mensonge donc voilà quand même dans
l'entourage proche de d'Evelyne un homme
qui a une relation intime avec elle et
qui veut la cacher et pourquoi veut-il
la cacher est-ce que ça en fait pas un
suspect formidable
devenu principal suspect François est de
nouveau auditionné par les enquêteurs
sans savoir que son ADN le trahit
François répète toujours la même chose
Evelyne est une amie rien de plus
j'ai déjà fait une déposition sur cela
depuis mars 2016 je n'avais plus de
relations intimes avec elle j'avais
simplement une grande amitié envers
Evelyne qui était un peu paumé
[Musique]
face aux mensonge flagrant de l'amant
les policiers lui présentent les preuves
ADN évidemment il est coincé et là il va
faire le chemin de dire bon
effectivement je vous ai pas dit toute
la vérité enfin je voulais pas que ça
s'est brûle moi je voulais surtout pas
que mon couple puisse en subir des
conséquences donc effectivement j'ai une
relation j'ai eu des relations avec elle
depuis qu'on s'est revu mais je tenais
pas à vous le dire parce que je veux pas
que ma femme le sache
il était clair que je ne voulais pas
quitter ma femme et quand Evelyne et moi
il ne pourrait rien y avoir
je ne veux pas casser mon ménage et ma
vie actuelle
[Musique]
les enquêteurs imaginent alors un mobile
possible et si François avait éliminé
Évelyne parce qu'elle devenait trop
compromettante pour son ménage
[Musique]
peut-être Evelyne aurait pu révéler au
grand jour l'existence de leur relation
peut-être souhaiter-il pas que
l'existence de leur relation soit
étalées au grand public
François continue à nier être le
meurtrier d'Evelyne cette femme pour
laquelle il avait des sentiments
les policiers vont alors vérifier son
emploi du temps
[Musique]
il retrouve notamment des ouvriers
témoins de ses déplacements et sans le
vouloir ils vont fournir au militaires
un alibi en béton
des ouvriers étaient déjà devant chez
lui puisqu'ils étaient en train de
construire une extension un garage à
l'extérieur de chez lui ces ouvriers
sont restés toute la journée ne l'ont
jamais vu sortir et ce que l'on sait
c'est que cette personne était déjà en
arrêt de travail qu'elle ne pouvait pas
conduire parce qu'elle avait des
douleurs aux cervicales c'était sa femme
qui l'emmenait aux divers rendez-vous
médicaux
c'est certain l'homme était chez lui à
8h45 puisqu'il a appelé un plombier afin
de lui demander de venir en urgence sur
son chantier un plombier qui passera un
peu plus d'une heure après
[Musique]
effectivement les plombiers sont
d'ailleurs passés à 10h du matin donc
sur le créneau qui est déterminé par les
légistes du de la mort d'Évelyne Furlan
manifestement cette personne n'avait pas
matériellement le temps ni physiquement
les capacités de venir dans
l'appartement de Madame Furlan
François l'examen de la victime et donc
innocenté
on va considérer que ces propos sont
fiables sont crédibles et donc par
conséquent on n'a pas besoin d'aller
plus loin dans les investigations
[Musique]
les policiers retournent à la case
départ
[Musique]
mais il leur reste une chance de
découvrir l'auteur du crime car les
résultats des analyses ADN effectuées
sur le câble ayant servi à étrangler
Évelyne furlant vont enfin arriver sur
le bureau du juge on retrouve l'ADN
d'octama aux deux extrémités de ce câble
ce qui veut dire que c'est pas quelque
chose dont il s'est servi régulièrement
où on retrouverait son ADN partout là
c'est vraiment dans la symbolique de du
lien qui va servir à étrangler on le
prend à une extrémité puis à l'autre on
fait le tour et on serre et là le fait
la présence de l'ADN aux deux extrémités
pour l'accusation était déterminée
et ce n'est pas tout
l'ADN de Monsieur Kutama est retrouvé
sous 4 des ongles de la main droite de
Madame Furlan sous les ongles notamment
l'ADN de Monsieur Kutama est retrouvé
sur le col de la chemise de nuit
mélangée à celui de Madame furlant dans
un échantillon de salive et on retrouve
sur un débardeur de Monsieur Kutama à
son domicile une trace de sang avec
l'ADN de Madame Furlan
[Musique]
Robert kudama est donc créé interrogé
par la juge d'instruction pour
s'expliquer sur tous ces éléments
accablants
et l'homme a une réponse limpide
c'est ADN pour nous et simplement signe
de la présence de Robert Koutama
chef-line Furon ce qui n'a jamais
contesté mais en aucun cas et le signe
du fait qu'il soit qu'il est commis
semeurent en tout cas qu'il soit
coupable de ce meurtre
il va dire bah oui c'est possible c'est
possible comme on ADN soit sur ce câble
parce que ce câble je m'en suis servi à
plusieurs reprises mais moi à donc un
cas je ne suis responsable de
de summertre en tenant le câble
uniquement par les extrémités mon client
aurait-il pu faire un double tour autour
du cou de la victime pour l'étrangler et
sans qu'on retrouve ces traces d'ADN sur
toute la longueur du câble
et surtout on ne comprend pas qu'il n'y
ait aucune trace de lutte et qu'il n'y
ait aucune griffure sur les mains de
Robert Koutama si c'était lui qui avait
commis ça fait là
concernant la tâche de sang sur son
débardeur voici ce que répond Robert
Koutama c'est une toute petite tâche ce
qu'il a encore ne veut rien dire et de
la même façon il y avait du sang de
Robert Koutama chez Evelyne sur blanc
lié à ses preuves de santé à lui ce qui
n'est en soi pas une preuve
l'avocat de Robert Koutama et met une
autre hypothèse
et j'en suis arrivé à la conclusion que
le meurtrier avait nécessairement porté
des gants et Robert Koutama de répéter
qu'il est innocent mais la juge
d'instruction n'est pas convaincue et
l'homme retourne en prison
[Musique]
voici en effet selon la juge le scénario
du meurtre
[Musique]
nous sommes en septembre 2016 et Robert
Koutama aurait découvert Kevin furlant
était en train de lui échapper elle
s'engagées un peu plus avec son amant
François le militaire
Robert Koutama lorsqu'il l'avait appris
avait pris un couteau et avait menacé
Evelyne furlant avec ce couteau en
disant tu peux pas me faire ça il faut
qu'il rentre les clés voilà c'est pas
possible et donc en acceptant pas du
tout le fait qu'elle puisse avoir un
autre homme dans sa vie et que cette
autre homme qui plus est puisse avoir
les clés de son appartement ce qui
n'était pas le cas de Robert coutamel
n'avait pas les clés alors là petit à
petit il va monter en croissance une
jalousie de plus en plus
enfermante et elle s'est sentie de plus
en plus menacée de plus en plus prise au
piège
et d'ailleurs il avait à plusieurs
reprises menacées Evelyne furlant soit
de la tuer soit de se tuer lui-même si
elle le quittait
la veille du drame le 30 septembre 2016
Robert serait venu voir Évelyne pour
obtenir une explication
mais tout ne se serait pas passé comme
il l'imaginait
alors le lendemain après le départ de
Julie au collège il aurait compris que
ça liaison avec Evelyne était terminée
et il n'aurait pas supporté cette
affront
Robert Koutama est fou d'amour pour
Évelyne Evelyne le trompe ce matin-là
elle va le quitter et il ne supporte pas
et il va la tuer
[Musique]
il a étranglé avec un câble électrique
dans le passant deux fois autour de son
cou et en très très fort très violemment
parce que la strangulation est très très
marquée très prononcée
et ce lien pour moi il avait un aspect
symbolique c'est le lien avec lequel il
a tue mais avec laquelle avec lequel il
la garde pour lui pour toujours c'est
aussi simple que ça reste à savoir si
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé mais
en tout cas c'est la version de
l'accusation c'est la thèse de
l'accusation
le jury suivra-t-il cette version dans
le procès qui va bientôt s'ouvrir rien
n'est moins sûr
10 février 2011 4 ans après le meurtre
d'Évelyne furlant
le procès de Robert Koutama s'ouvre à
Montauban
au moment où s'ouvre le procès rien
n'est joué on est sur un accusé qui a
toujours ni les faits toujours depuis le
1er jour il n'y est fait et avec un
dossier qui est extrêmement fragile pour
ne pas dire bancal
un procès en forme de confrontation
entre Julie la fille de la victime et
Robert Koutama l'excompagnon une
confrontation très difficile pour moi
quand je le voyais j'avais que de la
haine je le détestais
je voulais la pire chose pour lui
c'était vraiment
quand je le voyais j'avais l'image de ma
mère donc
de savoir ce qu'il avait fait et
[Musique]
je pouvais pas voir autre chose c'était
pas possible froid c'était un monstre
[Musique]
à l'audience Robert Koutama fait preuve
d'un comportement qui joue contre lui
Robert Koutama se défend très mal
a du mal à expliquer l'amour qu'il avait
pour Évelyne on a beau essayer de
travailler avec lui il n'y arrive pas
parce qu'il ne comprend pas qu'on puisse
l'accuser et qu'on puisse l'accuser
d'avoir tué la femme qu'il aimait donc
en l'état c'est très complexe ce dossier
et ce procès va être compliqué pour nous
en tant que la défense car notre
principale ennemi ce sera Robert
koutamment
quand il répondait aux questions il
était timide il
répondait aux questions qu'on lui posait
mais sans aller au bout comme un gamin à
qui on fait des reproches quoi
je l'ai senti très tendu très crispé
angoissée
c'est au tour de Julie de venir à la
barre témoignée
l'émotion de la jeune fille va
bouleverser les jurés
des fois j'aimerais ne plus y penser
honnêtement j'aimerais ne plus avoir
cette image là mais c'est dur c'est
encore dur même à 22 ans c'est encore
très dur
cette image là qui ça me choque en fait
c'est ma mère donc de l'avoir comme ça
c'est dur
[Musique]
les avocats de Robert Koutama eux
accusent le coup
ils tentent de répéter une ultime fois
que selon eux leurs clients n'avait pas
de mobile pour tuer Evelyne
ce qui est compliqué dans ce dossier
c'est que le mobile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'idée n'était pas temps de l'accuser du
meurtre c'est pas ça c'était simplement
de montrer que la position de l'amant
correspondait exactement à celle de
Robert Kutama au niveau des mensonges
des contradictions simplement que le
traitement qui devait être réservé
n'était pas le même que celui de Robert
Koutama les avocats vont s'engouffrer
dans cette brèche
et ils auraient eu tort d'ailleurs de
s'en priver et manifestement il y a des
choses qui n'ont pas fonctionné dans ce
dans cette affaire en tout cas il y a
trop de doutes me semble-t-il pour pour
juger sereinement
après quatre jours de procès les jurés
partent délibérés
ils ne leur faudra que deux heures et
demie pour tomber d'accord sur le
verdict
un verdict lourd
mais qu'on a 18 ans de prison du temps
de révision criminelle
il est
complètement décompensé et je crois que
c'est à ce moment-là qu'il comprend
qu'on l'accuse du meurtre des vignes sur
l'an et qui vient d'être condamné pour
les mains de la femme qu'il aimait
Robert Koutama fait immédiatement appel
il est rejugé dis-moi plus tard à
Toulouse la peine est alors alourdi à 20
ans de réclusion alors là c'était le
choc le choc et même aujourd'hui je suis
sûr qu'il sait pas pourquoi et pourquoi
il se demande encore qu'est-ce qu'il
fait là quoi
ça Robert Koutama qui continue de clamer
son innocence
be la fille de la victime éprouve une
peine immense à sa tristesse s'ajoute
l'incertitude elle ne connaît toujours
pas les circonstances exactes de la mort
de sa mère
j'aurais aimé qu'ils disent la vérité
j'aurais aimé qu'ils disent oui c'est
moi qui l'ai fait peut-être que ça
m'aurait permis d'avancer mais non c'est
j'ai toujours ce manque-là et je sais
très bien que je connais très jamais la
vérité je le sais et ça me bloque je
sais pas vraiment qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi il y a eu ces déclic là
pourquoi il a fait ça et j'ai toutes ces
questions là j'aurais jamais la réponse
[Musique]